the town of Rolling Fork in the rural
Mississippi Delta took a direct hit from
a tornado on Friday night and accounted
for the majority of the casualties such
was the power of the tornado debris was
reportedly thrown thousands of meters
into the air
we got a
modular home damage we got people not
accounted for at the time probably
tomorrow we have a full count on the
damage and the people that's not in
place
daylight revealed a town devastated
around a third of the residents here
were reported to have lived in Mobile
Homes a state of emergency was declared
in the western Mississippi counties
struck by the storm and across
Mississippi and Alabama there were
reports of leveled buildings overturned
cars downed power lines and trees given
the scale of the destruction there were
fears that the death toll could rise
search and rescue teams were deployed
Saturday morning to find those trapped
we lost everything but we got our life
told the house out told him a truck out
the car and other car but we good
there were multiple reports of tornadoes
amid the storm system and the National
Weather Service sent investigators to
ascertain whether many of those reports
were for the same tornado tracking
Northeast across the region for over 130
kilometers we can think that it's only
one single tornado tracking over a very
long distance but as those damaged
surveys are conducted they can see those
missing points between tornadoes and
determine if it was one long tornado or
multiple large tornadoes produced by the
same storm which is equally as
impressive tornado season is only just
beginning in the South and already there
have been several devastating incidents
meteorologists say this storm system was
fueled by the extreme weather patterns
and high ocean temperatures that have
become so common now as climate change
bites chabertansi Al Jazeera